[Music]
all right I know you guys probably went
for this one ever since we reviewed the
infamous we just shark and I said that
there was another movie that had been
put out by the same production company
while died releasing that had that got
like a lot of buzz like when it first
came out this is the velociter yeah this
like me was a [ __ ] blast yeah this
one was better than we do shark way
better well yeah because the thing about
it and we said this in our Regis shark
review that I really liked the concept
if we just shark but I wish it had been
more ridiculous yeah this one is more
ridiculous yes more different and it's a
delight and it's it's more
professionally done to that's it yeah it
seems less homemade yeah and the actors
are really selling it the [ __ ]
just ridiculous yeah this is exactly
what I meant when I said that if you if
you're gonna do a ridiculous premise
like this just lean into the [ __ ] so
it's a werewolf movie basically except
except it's a priest
except he turns into it to death into a
dinosaur and this happened this happened
because he went to China and some ninjas
were chasing a buck girl who'd shot hurt
and they shot her full of arrows and he
tried to save her and somehow she had a
damn claw and her blood mixed together
and he got it on got on him and she
passed on you know being basically like
being a wearable because it's a it's a
we're dinosaur yeah so whenever he
whenever he gets mad it's kinda like the
Hulk he turns into a damn dinosaur and
this shit's just [ __ ] ridiculous it
is and but it's so great and the thing
about it and here's like kind of all go
off on like a little bit of a
philosophical discussion because usually
when okay so Len usually when they try
to make a movie that's so bad it's good
it that's a hard thing to try to do
because a lot of times I feel like
they're trying too hard or it's just not
coming out right you know what I mean
it's like you know I think stuff like
sharknado which actually they succeeded
in doing max they were trying to make a
bad movie that was exiting actually
Nazis from the funny earth right it's
like those 60
but I think most of them kind of fail
like I said they're not as funny as they
think they are [ __ ] like that this one
is exactly right they hit this tone
exactly right
this movie costs $35,000 to make
apparently the guy that directed it
Brendan steer he said that he first had
the idea for doing this back in 2010 he
said it was because when he was typing
on his phone and he was typing
Velociraptor and it autocorrected to
velociter and he was like holy [ __ ]
that's 20 is al so he came up with this
whole idea so he like tried to do a
Kickstarter and said that didn't work he
try to do an IndieGoGo and that didn't
work and then finally he found a private
investor that was willing to give him 35
grand to make this movie it actually
came out in 2017 although at festivals
and stuff but so there have been a lot
of buzz about it but I think it didn't
really kind of get a wide dissemination
till later and like I said if you want
to watch it it's on to be for free like
yeah it's crazy it's kind of like a Rudy
ray Moore flick I mean it's got pimps in
it it's got ninjas in it it's got
dinosaurs in it it's got [ __ ] got
everything in it pretty much everything
every Phnom flashbacks
yeah just [ __ ] crazy this pastor gets
a girlfriend who's a hooker she kind of
to me she look like Claire Danes a
little bit yeah I thought she did and
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous man and
it's [ __ ] hilarious I mean when he
turns into the [ __ ] philosopher when
he turns into the dice or I mean it's
it's obviously a foam rubber outfit well
no it is yeah and you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
with you they're trolling you through
the whole thing I mean it looks like
something directly out of the old land
of the lost [ __ ] television not even
not good and that when guys are falling
being killed you can tell us this shot
with like a hand camera and they zoom in
on a dude as he's dramatically dying and
[ __ ] like wow look at that
and it's going on it's just [ __ ]
hilarious but it's the way it's shot and
it's done made during this [ __ ] on
purpose yeah it's very self-aware yeah
but not in an obnoxious way and like I
said it's that's very very hard to pull
off but they did it they they just
walked that fine line like exactly right
yeah and then when they don't have the
money for the [ __ ] effects they just
show something blank and it just says
you know effect here Carrboro see yeah
that's what that's what I knew that I
was gonna love this movie this happens
like in the first like couple minutes of
the film so like the pastor whose name
is Doug I think his name's Doug Jones
and he's like all like happy with his
parents everything like that his parents
are like waving by the car like and then
it's like and then there's like a light
and then he's like no and then they show
back and there's like a blank curb and
then it says VFX car on fire acted to
just the bucket just to the tape card
it's just [ __ ] hilarious
is it one thing that makes it is like
actually the acting in this is actually
good yeah they all care about it they're
all [ __ ] so yeah and they look like
they're having a good time it's like I
think they played it really really
straight-faced
they don't do like everything over Torah
is not Winkie or anything like that
they're just like playing it very
straight faced and very um you know
they're just kind of genuine and that
like makes it a hundred times funnier
and because we're acting yeah it's just
like and they're making fun of so many
different troops it's like some of the
best like [ __ ] in it isn't even real
overt you know what I mean like the [ __ ]
about like we're you know his parents
blow up and then like in the VFX or
whatever and then the other priest is
like you know he's trying to console him
and he's like you know parents died
that's what they do and like [ __ ] like
that
so he's like why don't you go somewhere
where God isn't and then if he follows
you there than something rather like
sounded deep so he's like so he goes to
China which is clearly like just a
section of a forest in New Jersey or
something and then it just says like
China really big on it and then he's
like walk through and going China and
it's like that same [ __ ] you know
part of the forest
later is used in like a nam flashback
yeah is fashion back to vietnam the
[ __ ] uniforms are all [ __ ] up
everything is wrong they're just out
looking for the Vietcong smoking
cigarettes it's just and then like for
some reason like the older priest father
Stewart like for some reason his wife is
there in a like ibly and like runs
against a woman by the way his mind goes
nothing more we can do she's just a
[ __ ] slag more we can do for ya it's
like the [ __ ] dinosaurs fight the
hook
the ninja and everything like that needs
got like a big gap in the bottom like
where you climb into the cops yeah and
he has like a big and even though it's
called like the velociter it's actually
looks more like a t-rex it's clearly
yeah and it's hard to tell when it's
happening I think it's supposed to be
happening in the 80s because there's a
lot of eighties tropes that's true it
yeah because it's it's hard to tell it's
hard to place it in time yeah I think
it's supposed to be happening in the in
the 80s that's why there's so many
ninjas in it yeah you know martial arts
and everybody's martial arts are just
like yeah it's just making this [ __ ] up
it's just it's just funny as [ __ ] but
like I said it it's really hard the
reason why it's so hard to do like a so
bad it's a good movie like on purpose is
because one of the things that make like
the the classic so about it's good
movies good is that they thought they
were making a good movie like Ed Wood
who thought he was making good movies
but they ended up just like hilariously
bad just because he was so earnest and
an incompetent so to do that on purpose
is really really difficult but I feel
like this one succeeded in spades
I mean this movie it's real short it's
only like an hour and 10 minutes long
and yet it shouldn't be any longer no
it's it moves it along just clip the
whole thing is just it's a delight to
watch like from start is super fun it's
like there's really no slow parts it's
like there's just every single scene has
something hilarious going on I think a
lot of the movies of the future will be
short like this I just think so yeah I
mean we're short too but there's gonna
be a lot of low budget movies that are
fun to watch like this because the you
don't have to spend much money on them
yeah and they [ __ ] it's a lot of bang
for the buck and you rent them for $2.99
and 399 off your [ __ ] xbox this is
really there just should be an entire
genre of these you know I mean you could
think you could make an industry out of
it and you know same thing with horror
alright why these two hour movie well
you know what good to [ __ ] two hours
movies that's too long well it depends
on what the story is it depends on the
story but it it has to compete against
your [ __ ] phones and tablets and
people are streaming from home they have
time to watch
but in two or three hours now maybe
they'll [ __ ] watch a series yeah yeah
I mean but to our movie a lot of times
it's overkill you love these stories you
can tell them in an hour yeah like I
said it depends on what the story is but
yeah most of my can make I could
condense to an hour but this one it
that's the thing about you know and I'm
not saying I'm not trying to [ __ ] on we
just shark because I did actually enjoy
that but I feel like a lot better though
well I feel like we just shark had like
a lot of filler and like a lot of stuff
that you know was too light like you
know people would walk through the woods
for like three or four solid minutes cuz
they were trying to like pad out the
runtime this one does not have that
problem it's like this one I'm not
saying there are like scenes like love
scenes and like fight they're like
really funny [ __ ] montages like he
has like a training montage where he's
like learning to be like bulk enough to
be Veloster and stuff cuz he's he wants
to go fight crime like the his hooker
girlfriend like convinces him to go yeah
kill all the bad people and her pimps
name is Frankie mermaid you guys just
got a lot of funny [ __ ] in every single
[ __ ] weed you shark was funny
I liked we just yeah but philosoph aster
you can tell that this is this is a work
of art there's somebody who this is a
man's vision and he's [ __ ] worked on
it you know I mean this this is it was
made with love oh you can tell that
everybody loved making this movie yeah
we just shark kind of felt a little bit
like they were just trying to knock out
just again because they don't like a
Ouija boards are big shark movies
they're just it'll be a gag and it'll be
you know people have fun let's just get
this [ __ ] rise yeah I feel like this one
vilasa pastor I mean you know like a
film well yeah and like like I said he
kid said he came up with the idea when
he was still in film school and so he
spent this long on trying to raise money
and try to and oh can we mention that
there's at one point the older priest
Father Stewart who was kind of his
mentor like Doug's mentor or whatever he
like um you know when when Doug says hey
I turn into a dinosaur like the first
thing father Stewart wants do is get him
an exorcism and The Exorcist is played
by Voltaire or Aurelio Voltaire
nowadays which if you were into goth in
the late 80s or early 90s like to mid
90s you for real when they do that is
because I didn't notice like in the
opening credits but when they had the
scene with the extras love is it
Voltaire that was I told Jenny but that
was like when I was in Boston that was
my best friend's axe
yeah yeah Tanya that was Tanya's [ __ ]
axe and he's been because I I like um
met him very briefly like at a horror
convention like many yeah yeah he came
to I bar yeah yeah talk like after a
show and you were talking to him because
yeah it sounded in common I was like
yeah we got somebody in common you know
this [ __ ] you know [ __ ] the tide
didn't he goes Tanya and he's like yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he knows yeah
beautiful girl work for Chanel she's
she's on my friends list you can see her
yeah but I was like yeah I was very
surprised like to see Voltaire in this
as and he actually like did a really
good job like as The Exorcist I thought
but it was like really funny but there's
like there's a million reasons to like
watch this movie seriously get some
beers um you know get your friends on
like you know whatever have them come
over if you don't want to do that you
know do it on you know zoom or whatever
and it's like get everybody to watch
this movie it is it is just delightful
it's just it's super fun it's just crazy
it's and and it knows what it is and
like I said this is exactly what I was
talking about this is what I wish we
just shark had done more of because the
the premise of that was like so funny
and like so stupid I feel like it didn't
live up to as funny as it could have
been it's a grass does it's a great film
in the way that bloodsport is a great
film yeah it's a great film in the way
that under siege is a great I like it
it's hard to kill I like this a lot
better than any of those I have to say I
had a lot more fun watching this one
blood sports pretty [ __ ] ridiculous
it is but blood sports [ __ ] you're never
gonna be as ridiculous as a priest that
can turn into a dinosaur
oh it's taking it to another level and
yeah and also there are niches that are
Chinese except one of them would speak
in Korean one of them so why
dude yeah and they're all and like I
said it's done on purpose you could also
tell that one of the ninjas was the same
guy who played the [ __ ] doctor - yeah
that was just cuz I loved the doctor he
was only in there for life but he had
like that thing on his head with the
with the merit it's like falling out
like it's too big and he's like smoking
in the office yeah like that it's just
there's just all these little touches in
there that it's just I don't know it's
like I feel like it shouldn't work but
it did this is like sublime this is a
sublimely terrible on purpose movie and
they just got they didn't nailed the
tone just right yeah it's hilarious it's
also very upbeat yeah it's you that's
what I mean it's just it's a joy to
watch it's super fun it's like it's
nothing like cuz sometimes you see you
know especially what cuz siloam and all
these other kind of like cheap Jack like
knockoff horror movies herb is like
what's the stupidest you know yeah 3
Headed Shark Attack 3 this then they're
boring and then you watch him and it's
like there's a couple funny scenes in
there but the rest of it's just kind of
like boring or it's just like exposition
or whatever this one is not boring this
one is just a lot of fun and like you
said you can tell that there's like so
much affection it was made with like a
lot of affection for the genre and for
the audience yes you know in the
audience [ __ ] tongue-in-cheek [ __ ] they
know they know that you know yeah so
it's just everything about this was just
like delightful and I just loved it and
I gots and lots of homage
yeah big time yeah but like I said not
in it not in an obnoxious like hipster
you know wink wink kind of way it's not
like that at all yeah I think that's why
it works become because it comes across
as very genuine you know and acting like
kind of portrays that like said they
just really really nailed it and um you
know everybody should really really
watch this movie cuz it's just it made
me so so happy and it's up there for
free it is yeah go which I mean if you
want to rent it and like you know you
know get I buy this one eh on blu-ray I
would and it's like really I kind of
hope and yeah actually after we watched
it I was like I kind of want to buy that
because that was like a it was a
wonderful wonderful man put that right
next to turbo kid and bloodsport yeah
it's just really fun it's just one of
those kind of like it was Friday night
Saturday night you know let's get drunk
and watch the Veloster yeah and just
watch this
this big big hunk bacteria
with a big hole in the bottom where the
dude crawls in the guys name like
fighting the people running and a hooker
ball diamond [ __ ] cartwheels know at the
beginning like before he becomes the
philosopher like when he's in China and
and he like the woman that has the tooth
or whatever that turned you into this
glob I think it's a year to throw a claw
or whatever it is and she gets shot with
an arrow like through the heart and
she's laying there I love that the
pastor Doug he comes up Tirzah
are you hurt there's like an arrow
sticking out there's blood it's just
it's so so sweet and it's so so funny
and it's just yeah it's you got to see
it it's like the they just there's so
many so bad into good movies that arch
that aspire to be this and this is just
exactly right they just did exactly
right and I hope that they make they
need to make some sequels to this
because they kind of left it open to do
that right I mean I would totally watch
the thing with a pastor who turns into a
dinosaur and his hooker sidekick yeah I
thought she died no she didn't know
that's right yeah yeah now what they
need to do is they need they need to
have the part - it has to have a kumite
in it yes they definitely needed to have
a I was like I was watching another
review of this because I mean ever
everybody that I've seen in this to
repeat this is pretty much the same
thing that we said it's like this is
just like so so fun yeah somebody in one
of the comments in one of the videos
they said oh if they do a sequel it
should be like set with the same
characters but like at the end of the
world or like Armageddon it should call
the loss of rapture yes yeah I was like
yeah see I would totally watch that you
know but yeah so it's free on to be or
like I said if you want to buy it you
know to give the guys some money like to
make some more movies because this guy
needs to make some more movies because
this this has made me happier than like
probably most movies that I've seen
lately it's just I don't know there was
just something really really charming
about it um so because it was maybe love
yeah so and you can really really tell I
mean it really does come across I'm like
I said if you're in if you're if you're
a goth fan and you know who Voltaire is
you know he's not in it he's not in a
really long time but he is in it and you
can tell he had a blast doing this as
well so you know definitely check this
one out this one is super super fun and
I reckon
that everybody needs to see it like
immediately
[Music]